hey guys hi morgan hey uh
congratulations on this movie i love a
film with twists and turns that i do not
see coming so thank you for that really
loved it uh drew you said you grew up
watching alicia in movies what was it
like when you found out that you were
working so closely with her on this
yeah um
for me it was uh it was a it was a bit
of a dream come true i mean obviously
look come on we're all very familiar
with with her and who she was and her
line of work but i also knew that there
was a a depth to her and that there was
there was just this immense
talent that that was just sitting you
know underneath the surface so i knew
that
you know not only was i getting to work
with someone who you know i am very
aware of and admire but someone who
is going to be so easy to kind of
bounce off of as an actor you know
um
your scene partner being as as
as talented as as these two are you know
i knew that my job was gonna be
inherently easier
um and i also knew that you know it was
gonna be great to kind of pick their
brains and and just you know i'm like a
sponge and i went to the set you know
very much sponge like and um you know
had a lot of questions and just watched
i watched them i i did a lot of watching
i'm an observer so i watched them both
um
very closely they might not know it and
that might sound very creepy but
you know
i did i did i was watching them and um
they're both so talented so
we were watching him just like seep up
all of the liquid that we left behind
they're like who is this guy just
staring he's like
[Laughter]
yeah but she she um she's very aware now
that i was a fan so thank you very much
but
yeah you know i i didn't i didn't let
her know i didn't let her know that i
feel like i hit it pretty well because i
wanted to to focus on the work so
i love that
alicia did he hide it well or does he
think he hit it well
well we're well you and i are wearing
matching tops i just noticed oh yeah
we've got the bow
um he hit it beautifully i didn't know
that at all ain't nothing yeah i love
that a cool cat
you're a good actor um you know
something that was really cool to find
out is the costume designer on black
survivors uh mona may is the same one on
clueless alicia what was it like
reuniting with her
well mona mae and i have worked together
four times i brought her on we did vance
together with amy heckerling where i
play a vampire
um i know that steven is the
is the vampire here but um
buy it and uh then
but then i brought her on to two
independent films i've done and this is
one of them because she's just
so good at spending no money because you
have they have no money in the budget
and so we go together and we get used
clothing we go to crossroads or buffalo
exchange and just get all used clothes
so inexpensive and you can build a
beautiful character that way and i think
she did an amazing job her the str the
vision board she had for each of our
characters clothes when she hadn't even
i didn't even think she'd seen steven
yet
um and she had a whole thing and and i
just went wow that those she just does
it elevates everything
yeah i love that you know steven so much
at the beginning of this film missing
troy's version of utopia you know very
secluded from the rest of the world what
would you say is your version of a
utopia
oh that's a good one um
honestly it there's there's very little
time in the world you know especially as
you get older you realize the sort of
the less time that you have so for me
like
my dream would be sitting in our house
in the yard reading a book while the
kids play and let me read the book
because that doesn't happen very often
um
so um
but yes it this this utopia is this is
this vision is this dream vision of my
character troyes where he has created a
world in which jake can exist and learn
everything that he needs all the tools
that he can have in the toolbox in order
to live life
um you know there's been this
cataclysmic event that has happened in
their world and the loss of jake's
mother
and he is bringing up so he's he's
mother and father to to this boy for 20
years and he's protecting him from the
outside and so i think a lot of people
and certainly friends who have seen it
sort of
look at that world at the beginning and
this sort of quite masculine sort of you
know
um
uh
world that they've set up where they're
cutting their own wood
they're killing their food they're
growing their food they are coexisting
together in this sort of wonderfully
beautiful symbiotic way and
it it feels perfect you know possibly a
little too perfect
yeah i like that i honestly didn't i i'm
not gonna ruin anything but it was just
so enjoyable to watch and figuring out
wait a minute something's not right here
uh drew when it comes to a
post-apocalyptic world who out of the
three of you do you think would survive
the best
oh um
i don't know
i'd say me because i don't have um
children
so i think that's something i don't have
to worry about
at this stage whereas whereas you know
these two do
um but stephen i will say see stephen
being being out there in the wilderness
and being very hands up very hands-on he
seemed to kind of know
his way around you know he knew his way
around an axe and you know chopping wood
and the fishing and all that so um
not
too count you out alyssia i'm sure you
would do great
but um
i don't know i'd have to say me just
because just because i you know i don't
have children but but stephen knows what
he's doing
i like that alyssia do you agree
definitely
i mean i'm i'm a nature girl so i could
definitely get i would figure that out
easily but i don't i don't
we wield an ax well
although i'm about i just could try
i'm down to try i just happen
and no i don't want to
awesome guys thanks so much for your
time it was really fun getting to talk
to all three of you thank you
you